[Musik]
eskalation am reichstag rechtsextreme
dringend zum parlamentsgebäude vor
politiker aller parteien reagieren
empört
aufstand in belarus zehntausende
demonstrieren trotz verbots gegen
präsident lukaschenko
es gibt zahlreiche festnahmen schlappe
für ferrari beim großen preis von
belgien fährt sebastian vettel nur auf
platz 13
hamilton gewinnt
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
unseren nachrichtenüberblick am sonntag
heute mit rudi cerne im studio für den
sport hallo an schönen guten abend
und noch einmal der blick zurück nach
berlin zu den gestrigen demonstrationen
gegen die anti corona maßnahmen die
sahen vor 19 uhr ja noch relativ
friedlich aus aus dem ruder liefen sie
erst unmittelbar danach als
rechtsextreme auf das parlament
zustürmten bundespräsident steinmeier
sprach heute von einem unerträglichen
angriff auf das herz der demokratie
hunderte rissen die absperrungen vor dem
reichstagsgebäude nieder und drangen bis
zur tür des bundestages vor
dort zeigten einige von ihnen symbole
wie die schwarz-weiß-roten reichs flagge
die von sogenannten reichs bürgern und
neonazis verwendet wird politiker aller
parteien reagierten entsetzt
andreas köhlers berichtet für den mann
der den moment filmt ist es ein sieg er
ist ein aktivist der neuen rechten und
hat mit ein paar hundert demonstranten
die absperrungen überrannt man sieht
zahlreiche reichs fahnen schwarz weiß
rot aber auch eine türkische flagge und
eine chilenische man sieht wie drei
polizisten versuchen die menge
aufzuhalten einer davon ohne helm der
sitz des deutschen bundestags muss
verteidigt werden
es ist in einer demokratie absolut in
ordnung corona maßnahmen zu hinterfragen
aber es ist in einer demokratie nicht in
ordnung die symbole der demokratie mit
autoritären symbolen zu beflecken und
hier vor dem reichstagsgebäude mit
schwarz weiß rot aufzumarschieren ich
bin sehr dankbar für die polizistin
polizisten die in dieser situation ihren
ansatz gezeigt haben und gehandelt haben
und wir müssen alles dafür tun dass
solche bilder vor dem gebäude des
bundestages nicht mehr entstehen
demonstration gegen die wie es heißt
corona diktatur auch heute mit putin und
trump fans mit der afd
offiziell verurteilt die partei die
gestrigen ausschreitungen aber wir haben
nicht eskaliert sondern die eskalation
das haben wir alles selber gesehen ist
von den polizeikräften ausgegangen
gegenteilig die einschätzung von allen
anderen parteien und auch die
schlussfolgerung insbesondere auch der
polizist ohne einen helm dem es höchste
achtung zu zahlen das ist eigentlich
jemand der ein bundesverdienstkreuz
verdient hat überwiegend kritik heute am
einsatzkonzept der polizeiführung und
überwiegend lob für den einsatz der
polizisten auch die cdu-vorsitzende
kramp karrenbauer reagiert empört auf
das was da am reichstag geschah sie sei
wütend weil das demonstrationsrecht für
nazi propaganda missbraucht worden sei
sagte sie im zdf sommerinterview
außerdem äußerte sie sich über ihre
nachfolge an der spitze der cdu und den
machtkampf in der union
mathis feldhoff es ist eine aufgebrachte
cdu vorsitzende die zum zdf
sommerinterview kommt angesichts der
gestrigen bilder in berlin scharf
verurteilt annegret kramp karrenbauer
die tumultartigen szenen direkt vor dem
hauptportal des reichstages
ich bin wütend weil hier aus meiner
sicht ein demokratisches recht in
demonstrationsrecht und das unbehagen
vieler menschen auch in der jetzigen
situation missbraucht worden ist für
nazi propaganda und jeder einzelne müsse
sich überlegen ob es gerechtfertigt sei
gemeinsam mit nazis zu demonstrieren
im innerparteilichen machtkampf glaubt
ak fest daran dass die cdu eigentlich
eine teamlösung erwartet aber keiner der
drei kandidaten seit der zeit bereit zu
verzichten
diese erkenntnis verbindet ak aber mit
einer warnung am ende des tages hat aber
jeder kandidat auch selbst die
verantwortung ob aus diesem
demokratischen wettbewerb aus aus einer
auswahl an guten kandidaten ein ruinöser
wettbewerb wird ein vorgeschmack auf den
wahlkampf zeigt die reaktion auf die
ankündigung des spd finanzministers
schon 2022 die schuldenbremse wieder
einzuhalten für die cdu vorsitzende ein
angriff auf den eigenen markenkern
wenn olaf scholz auf einmal ein
glühender anhänger der schuldenbremse
geworden ist dann hat das eher was mit
seinen ambitionen für das nächste
wahljahr zu tun als mit echter
überzeugung die cdu stand immer originär
für solides wirtschaften ich stand immer
originär für diese schuldenbremse
wir sind das original und da brauchen
doch keine kopie es ist ihr letztes zdf
sommerinterview
die wollen unbedingt dass der parteitag
im dezember auf dem ihr nachfolger
gewählt wird auch tatsächlich
stattfindet das vollständige gespräch
mit der cdu-vorsitzenden sehen sie im
zdf sommerinterview im anschluss an
diese nachrichten oder auch in der zdf-
heute- app mit der sie immer auf dem
laufenden sind und nun der blick auf die
aktuelle coroner lage in deutschland
da geht die zahl der gemeldeten
neuinfektionen leicht zurück im schnitt
der vergangenen woche haben sich täglich
1280 menschen neu angesteckt gestern lag
der wert noch bei 1300 kinder sollten in
diesem herbst gegen grippe geimpft
werden
das sagte der vorsitzende der deutschen
gesellschaft für pädiatrische
infektiologie hübner der welt am sonntag
kinder übertrügen das influenza-virus
maßgeblich auch gesundheitsminister
spahn warnte gleichzeitig eine größere
grippewelle und die korona pandemie das
könne das gesundheitssystem nur schwer
verkraften
und wir schauen nach belarus wo sich die
opposition weiter nicht unterkriegen
lässt
heute wieder massenproteste in der
hauptstadt minsk gegen staatschef
lukaschenko auch an seinem 66
geburtstag zogen zehntausende durch die
straßen und forderten seinen rücktritt
die autoritäre staatsführung hatte die
kundgebung verboten und ließ die
sicherheitskräfte hart durchgreifen
christian senn berichtet zahlreiche
festnahmen schon vor beginn der proteste
am mittag in minsk 125 gab es insgesamt
sagt das innenministerium mit
martialischen absperrungen hatten
polizei und spezialkräfte versucht die
menschen auseinanderzutreiben neue
massenproteste wollten sie im keim
ersticken
doch die menschen gingen trotz verbote
und einschüchterungen in vielen städten
denn belarus wieder auf die straße nach
schätzungen waren es hunderttausende
heute am 66 geburtstag von präsident
lukaschenko
wir möchten endlich auch mal ein
geschenk bekommen nach all diesen 26
jahren wir beanspruchen nichts wir
wollen gerechtigkeit
alle wollen veränderungen und man merkt
dass daran dass die leute rausgehen und
das die meinung der mehrheit ist auf die
frage wie lukaschenko seinen geburtstag
verbringt antwortet sein pressesprecher
mit diesem foto mit maschinenpistolen
und schutzwesten vom präsidentenpalast
und aus der region gomel wird noch ein
organisierter gruß von
militärangehörigen verbreitet ihr ganzes
leben zeugt von selbstloser hingabe
gegenüber dem belarussischen heimatland
und im eigenen volk heißt es im
geburtstagsbrief in den ohren der
demonstranten muss das wie hohn klingen
am mittag ließ lukaschenko
schützenpanzer durch die hauptstadt
fahren er will weiter ängste schüren als
am abend der regen kam zogen die massen
wieder ab aber sie wollen wiederkommen
mutige menschen und schon sind wir beim
sport an der formel 1 rudi du bist dran
genau schon ein gewohntes bild
formel-1-weltmeister lewis hamilton
gewinnt den großen preis von belgien in
spa frank und setzt seinen triumphzug
unaufhaltsam fort für sebastian vettel
war es wieder einmal ein enttäuschender
tag in seinem ferrari landet er nur auf
platz 13
mit spielerischer leichtigkeit dominiert
lewis hamilton dieses rennen in spa
francorchamps sein 89
karrieresieg mit riesenschritten in
richtung wm titel nummer sieben
sebastian vettel muss erleben wie kimi
räikkönen im ferrari kundenteam alfa
romeo an ihm vorbeizieht immerhin kann
der viermalige weltmeister team kollegin
claire hinter sich halten
hamilton bottas und fast appen sind die
besten drei dieses rennens vettel und le
claire auf 13 und 14 fiasko für ferrari
der franzose schuljahr philipp vom team
drilling quick step ist sieger der
zweiten etappe der tour de france in
einem packenden sprint setzt er sich
nach 186 kilometer rund um nizza gegen
den schweizer markt hirschi und adam
yates aus großbritannien durch knapp vor
dem hauptfeld aller philipp ist jetzt
auch gesamtführender und trägt das gelbe
trikot
ja und triple sieger robert lewandowski
vom fc bayern münchen ist zum ersten mal
deutschlands fußballer des jahres
er setzt sich bei der journalisten wahl
ebenso durch wie sein coach hansi flick
der trainer des jahres wurde bei den
frauen gewinnt pernille harder vom vfl
wolfsburg
sie spielt übrigens heute abend im
champions league finale gegen olympique
lyon
und er macht ernst einen tag vor dem
offiziellen trainingsauftakt des fc
barcelona ist der wechselwillige lionel
messi nicht zu den obligatorischen krone
tests erschienen
damit ist er für das mannschaftstraining
morgen gesperrt die spanische liga
bestätigt unterdessen dass messi nicht
ablösefrei gehen könne
verschiedene medien bezifferten die
ablösesumme auf 700 millionen euro
ein batzen geld ist das und das was vom
sport danke rudi und wir haben noch die
wetteraussichten für morgen im süden und
osten häufig schauer oder gewitter im
norden mehr sonne und nur vereinzelt
regen bei 15 bis 22 grad
das war es für heute danke für ihr
interesse
christian sievers meldet sich um drei
viertel 10 mit dem heute-journal und wir
sind morgen wieder für sie da punkt 19
uhr einen schönen sonntagabend wünschen
wir und verweisen jetzt auf das
sommerinterview von chuck und energy mit
annegret kramp karrenbauer